putting monologue we have another day
another shameless excuse some frankly
outright lie
from press secretary circle back gen
saki on joe biden's never-ending flub
struggles and now stumbling now she was
asked about biden's friday stair fall
here's what she said
just checking on the president he fell
going up the steps to air force one on
friday is he doing okay
he's 100 fine i don't know if you've
been up those steps they're a little
tricky sometimes
first they blame the wind now it's the
tricky stairs those are very tricky
stairs
donald trump probably used those too i
bet donald trump did this
no the real reason is obvious joe biden
is weak frail and a cognitive mess
that's the truth and of course as you
remember the mob the media
had no problem recklessly repeatedly
speculating about
president trump's health after he
gingerly walked down that one
time a wet slippery ramp at west point
with dress shoes on
but suggested that he was in some sort
of mental decline
and look at this a new analysis finds
that fake news cnn spent
a whopping 15 seconds on how joe biden
quote struggled to find his
footing on the windy morning that's not
what happened
compared to that whopping 22 minutes 13
seconds
fake news cnn dedicated to the ramp that
trump used while speaking at west point
and the commencement ceremony in june of
2020
it was the only time president trump
walked slowly
in dress shoes because it was slippery
and he had those shoes on so he was
being smart
no other time did president trump have
any issue or does he have any problems
talking to
the media if anything his only problem
was he talked to them too much
here to react to this and much more fox
news contributor former speaker of the
house newt gingrich
are you buying the wind bloom over
excuse
are you buying it with slippery are you
buying that
that that all of these flubs are
just you know joe being job because i'm
not buying any of it
look i have to confess as you walk
through all that
i was reminded of the old joke that
christ walks on water and it's reported
in the washington post
he can't swim
whatever trump did was bad whatever
biden does is good
let's start with that and that tells you
a lot about how misinformed
the american people are and what a
dereliction of duty
the news media is engaged in i think if
you went back and you watched everybody
who went into air force one in the
modern form
george h.w bush bill clinton george w
bush barack obama donald trump
none of them seem to be affected by the
wind so
this is all malarkey i mean we're going
to have to figure out a term
to deal with a press secretary who's so
cheerfully dishonest
that we have to have some kind of way of
just shrugging and saying
there she goes again to quote ronald
reagan
she has an impossible job and her answer
is
routine 100 dishonesty
she's not a press secretary uh she's a
propaganda defender
of impossible situations all right let's
look at this
so we just did a 1.9 trillion with a t
covert emergency relief bill with only
nine percent going to
emergency covert relief but it's a big
blue state
bailout now they're going to spend 3
trillion
more dollars on infrastructure a lot of
the money
which is going to obamacare a lot of
which is going to the new green deal
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
billions of dollars not millions
billions
three trillion total and we still
haven't even gotten to the budget part
of their job
now i'm not a mathematician i didn't go
to mit
i don't even need my calculator to
figure out uh
the math doesn't add up and i don't care
how high they want to raise
taxes look a couple quick things about
this
first of all you have to recognize this
is a machine
i mean how do you get every single
democrat in the house to vote the same
way how do you get every single democrat
in the senate to vote the same way
it's a machine there's no representing
the american people
they represent the machine how do you
keep the machine together
you pay it off on values so you pass
bills that are horrible
unless you're a woke left-wing democrat
second it comes down to the jerry
maguire movie show me the money
these guys have to spend all of this to
pay off all their allies
to try to hold their system together
because without the taxpayers money
their system is going to collapse that's
what's happening in new york
in new jersey in connecticut in illinois
in california and so there's a
desperation
underneath all this to be able to rip
off the american people
transfer it to their allies meet the
demand of jerry maguire
show me the money and pretend that
they're doing it for the american people
all right i think conservatism that and
we've been friends a long time
simple we believe in liberty we believe
in freedom
right we we we believe in limited
government
liberty and freedom we believe in the
constitution including the first
and second amendment just a little side
note there lower taxes
right we believe in energy independence
secure borders
we want law and order peace and security
in every city in town we want choice in
education
we want constitutionalists on the bench
i don't think any of that's complicated
free and fair trade and peace through
strength
now if every republican ran on that
contract with america would they win
i think they'd win a landslide look let
me give you this one number
90 of the american people and by the way
92 percent
of hispanic americans believe every
immigrant
should be tested for covet now if you
have a 90 percent issue
i don't understand why the republicans
aren't offering an amendment in the
senate
every day and offer aren't moving a
petition in the house
and just force the fight that's how far
away from reality the democrats are
they're a machine with no ties to the
american people
mr speaker always great to have you
thank you sir one week